I have to apologize to you today I made
a mistake on a story I got a story wrong
and I want to fix it today Donald Trump
has been floating the idea of cutting
the employee side of the payroll tax for
the rest of the year as a way to get
more money in people's pockets people
earning under 138 thousand dollars per
year I have multiple times said I was
supportive of this idea because it is
true that it would in the immediate put
money back in the pockets of workers
earning under a hundred and thirty eight
thousand dollars a year but I was wrong
to support it I was wrong and I'm going
to explain why today now for people who
don't know why or what the payroll tax
is if you are a normal w-2 employee
you're not a you don't work for yourself
you're not a small business owner you
just work somewhere like most people do
you and your employer share some taxes
that come off of your payroll up until
you earn one hundred and thirty seven
thousand seven hundred dollars per year
once you get to 137 seven per year you
no longer pay these taxes there are two
taxes 12.4% towards Social Security and
2.9 percent for Medicare okay it only is
on the first hundred and thirty seven
point seven thousand dollars a year that
you earn that is a total twelve point
four and two point nine that's about
fifteen point three percent the worker
pays half and the employer pays half so
the fifteen point three percent is split
seven point six five percent for you
seven point six five percent for the
employer Trump's idea was let's suspend
the employee half seven point six five
percent through the end of the year but
you would have to pay for it when you
file your taxes in 2021
for this year so it is not a cut it is a
tax holiday now initially I said listen
I do like it because it puts money
directly back in the hands of people
earning under a hundred and thirty eight
thousand dollars a year right now it is
not a tax cut for the rich and I thought
it was a good idea
I was wrong to support him for three
different reasons and most importantly
this is another way to actually back
handedly weaken Social Security and
Medicare and I want to go through each
of these reasons one by one so three
parts here number one the people who are
in the roughest shape right now are the
35-ish million people who lost their
jobs if you lost your job you're not
paying a payroll tax because you don't
have a job so seven point six five
percent tax holiday off the payroll tax
for people who aren't on any payroll is
not useful at all
second the people who do have jobs are
mostly earning the same amount of money
now I'm not saying they wouldn't love
not to pay this seven point six five
percent but you've got thirty five
million people that straight-up lost
their jobs so to them the payroll tax
holiday doesn't make a difference most
people fortunately for now are still
working and have not seen a decrease in
pay some people are still working but
have seen a decrease in pay but it is
not that many people the bulk of the
workers right now have not seen a
decrease in pay or are completely
unemployed and thus unaffected by a
payroll tax holiday and then number
three it is only a tax holiday this is
not a tax cut if you earn a hundred
thousand dollars for example in a year
that means in the second half of the
year you would expect to earn about
fifty thousand dollars for now saving
seven point six five percent puts thirty
eight hundred dollars back in your
pocket but it is only a tax holiday when
you file your taxes in 2021 and you
punch in how much you've paid for Social
Security and Medicare TurboTax or
whatever your accountant whoever will
spit out hey
that thirty eight hundred dollars you
didn't pay in the second half of 2020
you've got to pay it back in right now
because it was only a tax holiday so
doing this payroll tax cut would target
a relatively small group it would
deprive the government of nine hundred
and fifty billion dollars in revenue
through the end of the year it would
weaken Social Security and Medicare
which could then open the door to dirty
tricks from people like Trump and Larry
Kudlow and others to say hey we got to
do something with Social Security and
Medicare we don't have that much money
because of the tax
holiday you put in place and you've
still got to pay it back next year so we
can't let them do it I apologize that I
was supportive of this early on given
everything we now know I cannot in good
conscience support this and I'm sorry
that I suggested that it would have been
a good idea we're gonna continue
following this on Instagram our
instagram is david pakman show you can
also follow me on instagram personally
at david pakman we'll take a quick break
and be back right after this